[Musik]
ob den hohen Bäumen
jetzt gerade ist es ein bisschen blöd
weil ziemlich rutschig ist durch ihr
Witterung aber sonst im Sommer macht die
ganze Sache sogar noch viel mehr Spaß
bei der Rettung der Hamburger
Speicherstadt
über den Gezeiten informieren das Wasser
ist unser Herr
oder im Kontakt mit Wildtieren
wenn ein Tiger einen töten möchte dann
hat man Stress und hat man auch ein
bisschen Angst knochenjobs in Flora und
Fauna sind echte Herausforderungen
wenn das kalter Wintertag im Landkreis
Wesermarsch bei 2 Grad plus und hoher
Luftfeuchtigkeit ist jede Arbeit an der
frischen Luft ein Knochenjob
für Baumpfleger wie Tim Beckmann ist das
aber kein Grund zur Klage
also hier hat uns Kunde engagiert um
diese Pappeln die hier am
Grundstücksrand stehen
auf fünf sechs Meter runter zu schneiden
und
somit einfach für Sicherheit zu sorgen
die waren jetzt schon relativ groß
gewesen wie man hier hinten an der an
dem Baum sieht
ein fellkran erleichtert die Arbeit der
Baumpfleger kolossal mit seinem langen
und drehbaren Teleskopausleger mit
Greifarm und fellkopf reichte in einer
Entfernung von bis zu 35 Metern
[Musik]
sauber und exakt geht der Schnitt durch
den Stamm
[Musik]
Steven otthold ist der Maschinenführer
konzentriert achtet er darauf dass
Stämme und Äste sicher auf den Erdboden
gelangen
ja das das Gewicht passt ne weil einmal
abgesägt ist einmal abgesägt und wenn
das dann zu schwer ist dann
ist das nicht gut ein zwei Mal ist es
passiert aber es ging noch also es war
der Kranich stehen geblieben
Tim Beckmann ist Baumpflege und
seilkletterer doch seine Expertise ist
bei diesem Auftrag nicht gefragt die
Maschine ist dem Menschen hier einfach
ein wichtigen Belangen überlegen
[Musik]
der wichtigste Faktor ist die Sicherheit
Arbeitssicherheit und danach kommt dann
der Faktor Wirtschaftlichkeit
genau
dem starken Greifarm und der Säge haben
die Pappeln wenig entgegenzusetzen aber
auch hier kommt es auf die richtige
Bedienung der Maschine an
ja im schlimmsten Falle
die Last wird zu groß der der Rotator
vorne in der Zange hält diesen Ast nicht
mehr oder diesen standteil das Gerät
dann unkontrolliert ins drehen kann
dabei irgendwelche Gebäude oder
irgendwelche Fahrzeuge Menschen im
schlimmsten Falle beschädigen verletzen
ja von dem her ist da immer wichtiges
Köpfchen einzuschalten wissen was man
macht
aber jetzt ein bisschen zu viel Spannung
auf dem Ast
und 400.000 Euro hat der fellkran
gekostet
doch manchmal spielt die Elektronik
nicht richtig mit
trotz aller norddeutschen Gelassenheit
Steven ist genervt
die ganze Zeit
bei jedem Schnitt spackt der rum
das ist richtig die Scheiße
ich kann nicht sein dass der andauernd
die blöde Verbindung verliert
aufgeben kommt für Steven aber nicht in
Frage vielleicht funktioniert die
Verbindung zum fellkopf später wieder
und der Auftrag kann doch noch plangemäß
abgearbeitet werden
nach ein paar Probeläufen scheint der
Kontakt wieder hergestellt der Greifer
reagiert wieder
mit den beiden Joysticks kann ich
natürlich das Fahrzeug schwenken den Arm
ausfahren hoch und runterfahren für
diesen kleinen Drehhebel hier oben kann
ich den gesamten Kopf nach links oder
nach rechts drehen habe ich hier meine
lasttabelle hier unten da wird mir die
Länge des Arms angezeigt die Höhe den
Arm Winkel in was für ein Winkel der
nach oben steht und den Radius wie weit
ich vom Fahrzeug gerade weg bin dann
kann man ein bisschen Gas geben hier an
der Seite habe ich noch ein kleines
Drehrädchen womit ich dann die Säge
aktivieren kann und dann schneidet er
den Stamm ab
seilkletterer bräuchten einen ganzen Tag
um so einen Baum zu fällen der fellkran
benötigt nur zwei bis drei Stunden
vorausgesetzt die Technik spielt Bett
[Musik]
wieder sensorproblem das sieht man auch
auf dem Dach wenn die rote Lampe
leuchtet dann hat er irgendwie ist dann
entweder zu viel Last im Kran oder halt
irgendeine Störung
Steven löst den Greifarm ob das heute
noch was wird
[Musik]
die Hamburger Speicherstadt ist
Weltkulturerbe und in Gefahr die
prächtigen Lagerhäuser sind auf
fichtenpfählen gegründet und ihr
Fundament bröckelt dahin mit großen
Aufwand soll die gerettet werden
zunächst einmal geht es darum die
grundsohle der flete zu stärken diese
Aufgabe haben sich die Wasserbauer
verschrieben Jan Dethloff und Christian
Hauff müssen mit ihren Kollegen heute
einen Pendant verlegen das ist gar nicht
so einfach denn das Fleet ist schmal und
Sie müssen an einem anderen Pendant
vorbei
auf die Seite
das heißt in Kilometer Rohre
die maßrohre die im Wasser sind wir drei
Stück mit dem Wort der King mit der
hinterer Kante halten wir dann an das
sehe ich aber dann haben wir ungefähr
einen Abstand von neun Metern ja ich
gebe dir wieder den Leser
Entfernungsmesser
dann guckst du ungefähr 9 Meter ne und
zeigt immer an für uns ist die Aufgabe
wir wollen dieses Ponton jetzt nach dort
hinten an die Wand in die Ecke bringen
das machen wir jetzt mit zwei Booten der
Kollege steht vorne als quasi
Bugstrahlruder für links rechts zur
Verfügung und ich mache den Rest hinten
wir haben ablaufend Wasser
heißt das Wasser fließt in diese
Richtung Boot ist so angebunden damit
wir aufstocken können also quasi Bremsen
ansonsten bei dem Wassermassen die hier
durchfließen hat man keine Chance
irgendwie von hinten das pondon
aufzuhalten
noch ist das zu verlegende Pendant durch
zwei Stahlrohre sogenannte Beine im
fleetboten verankert diese muss
Kranführer Christian Hauff jetzt anheben
damit das Pendant geschoben werden kann
mit einem dicken Sicherungssplint wird
verhindert dass das Bein wieder in die
Tiefe rutscht jetzt ist Konzentration
gefordert
und das war halt hier gerade durchfahren
das ganze beobachten und wenn es eng
wird Bein runterlassen dass wir
aufstocken
auf geht's links liegt ein anderes
Ponton im Weg Rechtsfragen
beleuchtungsstrahler Meter weit übers
Fleet beides soll nicht berührt werden
das Problem ist die bewegungsträgheit
des Pendants
zwei Arbeitsboote ziehen und drücken das
Portal durch den Flut
Sehnen können sich die beiden
Bootsführer aber nicht das führt zu
Abstimmungsproblemen und am Ende der
engen Passage zu einem leichten Rempler
passiert ist aber nichts aber noch ist
das Ziel auch nicht erreicht
[Musik]
10 Meter 30
die Männer haben exakte Koordinaten
bekommen
was genau
der Plan habe ich da Glas weniger
sollen von dieser die sind ja nicht
gegenüberliegend
Plan ist ja geduldig
die genaue Lage des Pendants ist wichtig
damit er am Ende dort trockenfeld wo der
mitgeführte Bagger auf den fleetboden
gesetzt werden kann um störende
schlickablagerungen einzuegnen doch
Christian Hauff macht auf ein Problem
aufmerksam
[Musik]
dass die dass wir den Schwimmer
dass er Klick im Schlauch ja aber wir
verholen erstmal einen 83 auf Position
und dann haben wir erstmal Ruhe dann
können wir uns auch im Schwimmbad
kümmern 83 ist die Nummer des anderen
Pendants im Fleet dessen Position
ebenfalls noch geändert werden muss
dorthin wollen die Männer jetzt
übersetzen Neuling Jan franke hat den
Bogen aber noch nicht ganz raus
ja am kurzen Ende ziehen ganz auf ganz
auf und am kurzen Ende ziehen du hast
noch eine Hand
so
die freundlich ruppige Ansprache nimmt
hier niemand übel
der 83er wird nicht mit den
Arbeitsbooten sondern mit Hilfe von
Stahlseilen verschoben diese müssen die
Männer nun an den Spundwänden befestigen
Jan Franke ist erst seit vier Wochen bei
der Truppe und noch etwas unsicher
[Musik]
was da rein nein
rein und die Stange
Kästchen drüber
da musst du tauschen
der Kollege versorgt Jan mit einem
größeren Schäkel um die dicke Tasse
festmachen zu können
das Auge
Ortswechsel zu osnabrück
Tierarzt Thomas Scheibe bereitet sich
auf einen Arbeitstag vor der viel
Aufregung verspricht seine beste
Freundin soll eine Spritze bekommen
Kollege Jannis Göttling unterstützt ihn
wir müssen heute
unbedingt die Tiger impfen ich habe da
schon
rausgesucht unseren Impfstoff wir haben
Tiere die Wildtiere sind das heißt sie
sind eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht an
den Menschen gewöhnt und das kniffligste
aber allen Einsätzen ist natürlich die
Arbeitssicherheit und die Sicherheit für
das Tier wenn ich ein blasrohreinsatz
habe und ich muss heute ein Tiger eine
Spritze geben mit einem Blasrohr da muss
ich natürlich gucken dass ich geschützt
bin das ist klar aber auch dass dem Tier
nichts passiert so wir laden auf und
dann geht's los
[Musik]
2200 Tiere aus 290 Arten beherbergt der
zu Osnabrück und alle haben ihre
Besonderheiten
[Musik]
gut so dann fahren wir los
bei seiner Gründung präsentierte dazu
nur heimische Arten heute gehören noch
Exoten wie die Sumatra Tiger dazu
also jetzt könnte man gut schießen aber
ich glaube sie will nicht mehr das war
jetzt so dieser ja diese Patienten ist
sehr aufgeregt also quasi wie man das
vielleicht als Katzenbesitzer auch kennt
die Katze möchte nicht geimpft werden
und unsere Tiere kennen ja teilweise
auch das Blasrohr und unsere Tigerkatze
kennt das Blasrohr sehr genau und
regt sich jetzt schon wenn sie das nur
sieht auf wir müssen Sie noch einmal in
eine andere Box sperren und ich spiele
so ein bisschen die tigerscheuche jetzt
also ich gehe einmal mit dem Glasrohr
vor und täusche an und dann wechselt sie
hoffentlich in die andere Box das ist
jetzt unser Plan gewesen
ein bisschen runterkommen dass sie sich
ein bisschen gut ich ziehe Spritzen auf
ne
auch die Katzen kann ich nicht aus der
Hand Spritzen ne so
die werden gegen auch Katzenseuche
Katzenschnupfen und wir haben einen
Staub im Stoff
das ist unser Standard Impfprogramm hier
für die Großkatzen soweit
Thomas Schreiber hat wenig Fans bei den
Tieren nein ja die merken sich natürlich
was passiert ist und ich bin meistens
mit negativen Assoziationen verbunden
dass ich da irgendwie den mal weh getan
oder Narkose gelegt habe und also für
ein Tierarzt
das ist immer so dass er nicht gerade
der beliebteste ist
langsam wird es ernst
richtige drin ist
also wenn ich den Impfstoff einmal
aufgezogen habe dann muss ich den auch
sofort verwenden oder verwerfen und das
ja deshalb ziehen wir mal kurz vorher
oder das Tier ist nicht im fähig kann
auch sein das ist krank ist dann dürfen
wir die Tiere auch nicht impfen da
müssen wir natürlich gucken die Tiere
sind aber soweit fit schon geguckt ja
dann kann es losgehen dann ziehen wir
das immer kurz vorher raus wenn ein
Tiger einen töten möchte dann hat man
Stress dann hat man auch ein bisschen
Angst dafür ist Angst ja auch mal
erfunden worden das ist ein bisschen
natürlich muss ich sagen
aber es gehört zum Job dazu und wir
machen es ja auch gerne irgendwie also
Thomas Scheibe ist bereit nur ist noch
nicht hundertprozentig klar aus welcher
Position erschießen kann
entweder die Katze oder ihn aber da kann
ich auch nicht schießen du kannst sonst
probieren ob sie hier reingeht wenn ich
hinten an der Tür stehe wenn die hier
drin ist kriege ich sie und dann können
wir einmal noch mal umschieben
wenn du jetzt wenn ich diesen Schieber
hoch machen soll muss ich diese Tür
schließen sonst funktioniert das
Sicherheitssystem nicht also du kannst
nicht an der offenen Tür stehen dann
macht die zu ja und probieren das einmal
sonst Thomas
von der Seite hier oder von der Seite
rein
das ist von der anderen Seite wenn ich
von der anderen Seite komme
ich gehe einmal komplett durch bis ich
aber es muss alles sicher sein
den Schlüssel kannst du nicht kriegen
solange ich ein Schieber auf habe okay
dann probieren
[Musik]
in Wartenburg ist ein seilkletterer Team
der Firma André Bischoff auf einem
Friedhof unterwegs Sven Schliep soll mit
seinen zwei Kollegen Robert lang und
Hanna Jansen abgestorbene Äste aus den
Bäumen holen damit sie nicht auf
Besucher und Gräber stürzen
[Musik]
erstmal den großen
und mit dem anderen
ich würde sagen der Baum geht so an die
28 Meter
ja aber ganz hoch muss man nicht da oben
ist dann eigentlich nichts relevantes
mehr
[Musik]
Vorbereitungen für den Aufstieg in die
Baumkrone
das ist jetzt eine Schnur die wird oben
rein geschossen manche werfen die auch
von Hand wir machen uns das ein bisschen
leichter und schießen die mit einer
Zelle hoch und dann wird daran nachher
dies aufstiegsseil
angebunden um dann an dem Seil hoch zu
klettern
Robert lang soll den kleinen Sandsack
mit angenähtem Faden so in den Baum
schießen dass die Kletterer einen
leichten Einstieg haben
[Musik]
so dann schießt du am besten da oben wo
der linke dicke stämmling hochgeht da
verästelt sich das ja dann wenn Du da in
diese Bereiche von 20 cm Durchmesser
rüberkommst dann wäre das natürlich
optimal
[Musik]
weiter neben aber das kann schon mal
passieren
Robert versucht es erneut
[Musik]
nicht optimal gelaufen
den hast du angezielt oder was
du siehst ja du siehst ja da wo wo jetzt
der Tote da dran hängt ne ja das Stück
das sind 7-8 Meter die du irgendwie
überbrücken müsstest ohne dass du ein
Ast zur Hilfe hast
Versuch Nummer 3
[Musik]
diese Versuch war besser aber immer noch
nicht ideal Sven schlieb erklärt worauf
Sie beim Einstieg achten
Richtwert wo wir sagen der hält uns auf
jeden Fall der muss natürlich vital sein
und zudem auch ja eine vernünftige
Position natürlich sollte der jetzt
nicht ahnlich und dann auf vier Meter
länger sein sondern immer stammnah ne
man weiß ja nie im Grunde ob der
komplett gesund ist ob er von oben
angerissen ist durch den Sturmschaden
oder wie auch immer aber im Grunde wenn
er am Stamm Alter ich sag mal eine
zentrale am am Stamm dran ist können wir
eigentlich uns immer sicher sein dass er
uns helfen auch dieses Mal war die
Flugbahn nicht perfekt
einmal versuche ich das gleich noch eben
der drüber einfach los ja da ganz oben
die letzte
rein und dann gehe ich dementsprechend
rüber macht ja nichts
wir wollen ja im Grunde eh nur einmal
hoch und dann vom Baum zu kommen
noch einmal macht Robert sich bereit
doch dieses Mal mit einem anderen Zielen
Visier mit Kraft und Konzentration soll
es jetzt gelingen
[Musik]
und der sitzt
Sven muss jetzt nur noch den Sandsack
runter und damit das Seil hochziehen
[Musik]
auf der anderen Seite runter
guten Morgen
hast du gut geschlafen
frei
Jan bringt die Männer das Unternehmens
mehr Naht zu ihrem Arbeitsplatz auf dem
Pendant der noch auf seine neue Position
gebracht werden muss damit sie zielgenau
bohren können
Christian Hauf achtet derweil darauf
dass die Stahlseile die nun aufgerollt
werden um die Position des Pendants zu
verändern sich nicht verheddern
ich kann ja auch probieren auf diesen
Punkt zu kommen vielleicht reicht das ja
schon ja genau guck mal nach was hast du
jetzt 20 oder ich muss erstmal die
Nummer einmal eingeben ja gib mal ein 26
und dann sagst du uns wenn stop wenn
ausreicht
langsam ziehen die Stahlseile das Ponton
in Position viel Spiel darf es nicht
haben
ungefähr auf 10 cm genau
und ansonsten ist das blöde ja er hat ja
ein Rastermaß das sieht man ja hier
diese Blöcke
1 2 3 4
so und steht jetzt soweit weg kriegt er
den letzten Block nicht und steht er zu
dich dran kriegt er den ersten nicht
also so ein kleiner Teufelskreis
deswegen und damit Toleranz wie gesagt
so 10 cm das ist in Ordnung plus das was
das Ponton sich bewegt auf den Bein wenn
wir auflaufen Wasser haben die Beine
werden immer länger nach unten hin und
dann schwimmt das Portugal ja hin und
her und das haben wir da schon mit drin
was noch weiter ja mega
ja wir sind schon negativ bereit ja pass
auf dann nehmen wir das Bein runter
drehen hinten rein dann kommt er vorne
raus da passt das
dann müsst lieber nach so 330
33 genau
also ein Meter noch an
1 Meter noch rein lass uns den
runterlassen ja da gehen wir erst mit
der Seite ran
das ist das Ergebnis einer veritabilen
Denksportaufgabe
so das ist jetzt wieder dieses Denken ne
dieses dieses umdrehen ne hier muss ich
die Position die weiter halten also
nämlich das Bein erst runter und drehe
mit dem hinteren erst ran auf mein Maß
um das Bein wieder hochzunehmen um hier
nach zu korrigieren
[Musik]
ja Wasser läuft ja sowieso ab ja
darüber ja warte wir holen den Rum und
dann kannst du gucken sechs Meter rüber
aber frei
um die fleetsohle zu stabilisieren und
damit die Kaimauern zu schützen werden
zwei Verfahren ausprobiert eines ist der
Bodenaustausch das andere eine
Stabilisierung des vorhandenen Bodens
er bohrt unten in die Erde in Loch rein
dabei wird Zement in den Boden geblasen
ne dann wird der Bohrer wieder
rausgezogen und so entsteht quasi eine
zementsäule ne gemischt mit dem Boden
der hier bereits vorhanden ist dass die
natürlich zur Stabilisierung von dem
ganzen flipboden ergo dass die Häuser
dass die Spundwände nicht rausdrücken
können etc ne sieht man auch bei niedrig
Wasser nachher das alles aus Holz ne und
teilweise ist schon ziemlich im
Mitleidenschaft gezogen das meiste wurde
dann ja hier 1888 gebaut und das auch
immer so eine Sache du musst dich
ständig über die Gezeiten informieren
weil wir haben ja nicht immer gleich
ablaufend und auflaufend Wasser das
steht festgeschrieben ne das Problem ist
wir haben dann manchmal mehr
niedrig Wasser also sprich weniger
Wasser oder höher dementsprechend
verkürzt oder erhöht sich das
Zeitfenster indem wir dann mal wegen
verholen können oder irgendwelche
Arbeiten durchführen ne das ist auch
immer zu beachten sage ich jetzt mal 12
15 Niedrigwasser dann ist hier kein
Wasser mehr drin wasser ist unser Herr
wir können auch da
im zu Osnabrück ist Thomas Scheibe noch
nicht zum Impfschutz gekommen
ja du bist ja ja es ist meine spezielle
Freundin hier
aber ich bin auch froh dass wir
Sicherheitsglas dazwischen haben muss
ich ehrlich sagen jetzt so sie mag mich
nicht ich hatte ja zweimal Narkose
gelegt das hat sie sich gemerkt und sie
mag das nicht und ja das zeigt sie auch
ganz klar das muss natürlich zu sein ja
absolut
okay
vorne ist zu jetzt noch mal gefragt
da ist jetzt alles so
okay lieber zweimal mehr fahren
okay
[Musik]
nein nein Pfeil denn die sind teuer okay
nebenan versucht Tierpfleger Stefan den
Tiger Kater in eine bessere
Schussposition zu locken unerfolg
[Musik]
Thomas Scheibe sucht die beste
Schussposition
doch der Tiger Kater bewegt sich keinen
Millimeter
[Musik]
lass das liegen nein
sehr gut gemacht danke
erstmal so muss das aussehen das ist
genau richtig der ist zurückgezogen wir
haben auch manchmal ein paar Haare
dranhängen soweit der ist vorne sie hat
sich entleert sie ist auch heile
geblieben soweit alles gut
alles super Stefan ich danke dir war top
die nächste Station der beiden Tierärzte
ist auch immer für ein bisschen
Aufregung gut den Bisons soll Blut
entnommen werden
alles klar
müssen wir heute eine Blutprobe noch
nehmen von dem Bisons müssen wir einmal
im Jahr machen steht jetzt an also
versuchen wir sie einmal durch diesen
Gang zu treiben und wenn sie gut stehen
dann kann ich von hinten von der
schwanzvene bis zum Blut nehmen
soweit der Plan als erster traut sich
Winnetou in die cattlebox
das hat bisher schon gut geklappt
[Musik]
die Haut an der Schwanzwurzel ist
relativ dünn und die Vene gut zu
lokalisieren
neue Kanüle
okay ist alles gut
Winnetou macht es Thomas Scheibe nicht
gerade leicht
bisschen
mehr Blut spendieren
[Musik]
bewegt sich hin
ich glaube wir können den durchlassen
der liegt jetzt bis er wieder steht kein
Blut nur so ein Tropfen vielleicht
reicht das ja auch naja ein bisschen
wenig rot vorsichtig
Thomas Scheibe startet einen letzten
Versuch ich darf nur nicht mein Arm
brechen lassen
gut so komm
doch Winnetou bleibt geizig jetzt
spendiert er kein Blut der steht da gut
[Musik]
komm raus ob jetzt genug Blut in der
Kanüle ist
das kann raus
bevor wir sich noch verletzt hier
sehen so ruhig aber wenn die das Kraft
das krafttrainer glaube ich auch richtig
Respekt vor auch ein bisschen mit der
doofe die können auch unheimlich hoch
schlagen also so unterschätzt man immer
weil sie sind so Baby aus die kommen
richtig hoch super
[Musik]
Winnetou
unterdessen versucht die Tierpflegerin
eines der anderen Tiere ins Gatter zu
locken
wenn Du den Eindruck hast das wird
nichts mehr sag Bescheid ne dann brechen
wir ab ein letzter Versuch die anderen
mit Apfelspalten zu überzeugen
ich denke die anderen haben gesehen was
jetzt passiert und ja mal schauen aber
jetzt kein Buch kriegen dann brauche ich
mal in der Regel ab und machen dann im
14 Tagen neuen Termin
heute wird also kein Blut mehr abgezapft
geduld ist gefragt
[Musik]
weiter geht es zum nächsten Einsatzort
zwei sehr schwere Zeitgenossen warten
auf die Hilfe der Tierärzte
Sven schlieb will hoch hinaus
wirklich trägt man weiß ja im Grunde nie
begebe mich dann Stück für Stück nach
oben
ein kräftezehrender Aufstieg außer Sven
Schliep wird auch noch sein Kollege
Hannah Janßen in den baumsteigen Robert
lang wird heute unten bleiben
[Musik]
wenn zwei im Baum sind und einer am
Boden ist dann ist es eigentlich immer
eine ganz gute ganz gute Aufteilung Mal
fällt eine Säge runter man braucht man
eine stangensäge oben
der Einsatz von Seil Klettertechnik
schont den Boden und der seilkletterer
sorgt dafür dass dicke Äste nicht auf
die Grabstellen fallen
Körperbeherrschung und Flexibilität sind
Voraussetzungen für diesen Knochenjob
schwindelfrei muss man natürlich auch
sein und wetterfest
[Musik]
jetzt gerade ist es ein bisschen blöd
weil ziemlich rutschig ist durch die
Witterung aber sonst
im Sommer macht die ganze Sache sogar
noch
viel mehr Spaß
die Seil Klettertechnik schont die Bäume
Steig Eisen nutzen die Baumpfleger nur
wenn der Baum gefällt werden soll beim
Sägen in den Baumkronen ist gutes
Gleichgewicht und Zielgenauigkeit
gefragt
nach gut zwei Stunden sind die Kronen
vom todholz befreit an einem feuchten
Wintertag wie heute reicht schon so ein
kurzer Einsatz um ordentlich nass zu
werden
ja es ist manchmal natürlich kalt also
gegen die Kälte wenn dann die Handschuhe
nass werden da kann man sich auch nicht
anziehen dann geht man mit kalten Füßen
und mit kalten Fingern nach Hause und
die tun dann schon manchmal weh
ja so schön nass jetzt ja mega ne
während das Seil Kletterer Team von
André Bischof seinen Auftrag erledigt
hat
ist der Kollege mit dem fellkran noch
damit beschäftigt eine Reihe Pappe 5
Meter zu kürzen
dieses Geräusch klingt nicht gut
wenn ich zu viel Spannung im Baum habe
dann klemmt die Säge unten beim
Schneiden ein und dann ist es immer
ziemlich schwierig den Punkt zu kriegen
dass die wieder frei geht und ich den
Baum ganz abschneiden kann
so wie jetzt
Metallbänder eingewachsen oder
[Musik]
das Sägeblatt kommt nicht durch den
Stamm
[Musik]
ist jetzt ein technisches Problem
entweder ist die Schiene irgendwie
verbogen krumm dass da keinen gerade
Schnitt mehr durchs Holz erfolgen kann
und somit
die Kette sich dann nur auf der Stelle
dreht quasi
das müssen wir jetzt gleich mal unseren
Boden angucken was da los ist
mach mal auf
jetzt ist die Schiene ganz krumm wie man
glaub auch vom Boden aussieht ja so
sollte die Schiene nicht aussehen etwas
verbogen mit einer Kurve drin
Tim und Stiefel machen sich an die
Arbeit ein ersatzsägeblatt haben sie
dabei obwohl so ein Malheur nur selten
vorkommt
schwierig zu sagen also im besten Fall
natürlich nie
aber hin und wieder passiert das einfach
ich sag mal von zehn Baustellen
vielleicht auf einer dann oder so
möglichst schnell soll das Sägeblatt
gewechselt werden damit auch die letzten
beiden pappelkronen heute noch fallen
können
[Musik]
doch das verbeulte Sägeblatt zeigt sich
störrisch Steven packt mit an
genau schon mal eine Gefahrenquelle
weniger
scharfe Kette
du bist einfach so hart
schließlich gelingt es den beiden das
Blatt zu lösen
da sieht man die ist zu nichts mehr zu
gebrauchen
mit wenigen Handgriffen montieren die
zwei das neue Blatt
[Musik]
so jetzt fehlt nur noch eine neue
Sägekette
wir haben hier unsere Schneidzähne
ja müssen natürlich scharf sein
sobald man
ein einzelnen Zahn wenn der schon ein
bisschen aus der Richtung läuft das kann
schon ausreichen dass die Säge oder die
Kette nicht mehr richtig schneidet und
man dann halt immer so ein Bogen da rein
kriegt
routiniert ziehen die zwei die neue
Sägekette auf
[Musik]
den Fehler behoben und es kann
weitergehen
Steven schwingt sich wieder in den
fellkram um die Pappel doch noch auf die
gewünschte Höhe zu stutzen
so eine neue Kette ausmacht
[Musik]
auch wenn sich der fellkran heute nicht
von seiner verlässlichsten Seite zeigte
ohne ihn hätte diese Aktion deutlich
länger gedauert
den Hamburg kämpfen Jan Detlef und
Kollegen weiter mit den Gezeiten und der
Aufgabe für einen möglichst
reibungslosen Ablauf der Arbeiten zur
Stabilisierung des fleetbotens zu sorgen
das ist ein zementschlauch der geht da
oben zum zementsilo da ist auch ein
Kompressor dran und so und da wird jetzt
Zement hier durch den Schlauch
durchgeleitet
zu dem Feeder zu den großen roten Dingen
hinten auf dem Ponton und der Feeder der
teilt das wieder ein an das Bohrgerät ne
ja die Schwimmer sind natürlich dran
damit die Leitung nicht unter Wasser ist
dass wir sie wiederfinden und ansonsten
ist es ganz im Prinzip ein bisschen
nervig weil wie du siehst ist verheddert
sich es verdreht sich es ist unser Weg
aber es ist nötig
Knicke im Schlauch verhindern den
problemlosen Durchfluss des Zements
wer verdreht ist denn muss ich nachher
mit mir Naht noch mal rausfahren dann
müssen wir einmal an der Kupplung
trennen oder muss er ihn ausdrehen nutzt
ja nix
die fahren auf der Leitung oben haben
die glaube ich einen Druck irgendwie bei
100 bar
und wenn wir dann Stau drin haben und
die Leitung sollte platzen dann knallt
das ganz schön ist auch schon passiert
so wunderbar
Zement sollte aber möglichst nicht in
das Wasser gelangen denn es erhöht den
pH-Wert und schädigt so die Umwelt
Jan muss ich jetzt beeilen wenn die Ebbe
zieht das Wasser aus dem Fleet in
wenigen Minuten wird hier alles auf dem
Trocknen im Liegen
damit öffnet sich ein kleines
Zeitfenster in dem ein Schwimmbagger
eingesetzt werden kann er soll die
unregelmäßigen schlickablagerungen ein
ebnen doch wie erkennt der Baggerführer
die Untiefen vorher Taste der ab mit
seinem Löffel bzw mit seiner Schaufel
wie der Untergrund ist und das muss er
sich dann ungefähr merken und hat dann
das Material was rund um das Loch liegt
was durchs bohren entstanden ist um das
Loch dann wieder zu verfüllen das hat
zum einen den Zweck dass wir den Boden
passierbar machen weil wenn wir wenig
Wasser haben müssen wir mit dem Boot ja
trotzdem fahren und bei so einer
Hügellandschaft
da stößt man sich dann schon an nur rund
80 Minuten hat der Baggerführer Zeit
dann strömt das Wasser zurück ins fliegt
Dominik Gerald erkundigt sich über den
Stand ja Wasser kommt wieder
ne er hat hier noch eine coole drinne
die ganze Fläche hier kannst dich daran
entsinnen hier waren diese Bänke diese
Aufspülung vom bohren ja also da wo er
angefangen hat hinten zum Ende vom
pantern bis hier vorne hin hat er eben
gekriegt wie gesagt hier vorne
selbst hier hat er den Grund jetzt sehen
da der noch mal glatt gemacht hier
genauso und auf der Ecke ist natürlich
nur noch Schlamm ne
bei den Arbeiten in dieser Umgebung ist
noch vieles zu achten selbst auf die
Sauberkeit der Maschine
der ganze Schlamm sammelt sich ja im
Fahrwerk und dadurch dass der Schlamm
trocknet verfestigt er sich ja ist ja
wie Lehm oder wie Gips und das nur ein
einfaches gleitfahrwerk ist an so ein
Bagger kann es auch passieren dass das
Fahrwerk fest wird
zwei der Grund ist natürlich man will
den ganzen Schmutz nicht auf dem Ponton
haben ne weil much wird rutschig und das
drehe ich dann noch mal dazu bei dass
das Ganze gefährlicher wird weil die
Oberflächen sowieso schon glatt sind bei
Regen und so ja und des Weiteren gehört
das eigentlich auch mit zur
Maschinenwartung und Pflege ne
der Zahn der Zeit lag dann der
imposanten Speicherstadt doch bis zum
Jahr 2030 soll sie wieder auf sicherem
Grund stehen so sicher wie jetzt auch
wieder der Schwimmbagger auf dem Punkt
Ankunft im Aquarium auf Thomas Scheibe
und Jannis Göttling warten die ältesten
Bewohner des osnabrückers
drunter gucken heute mal
die leichtere die leichtere genau ja die
haben ja locker 200 Kilo
okay
ja Mama so ein bisschen schmott unter
der Panzer das wird aber schön sauber
damit mal gucken können dazu müssen die
Patienten auf die Seite gedreht werden
in die Richtung okay gut
oder soll ich
okay
sehr gut
also es sieht relativ gut aus und das
riecht auch relativ gut
da haben wir noch ein bisschen
tiefstreifen okay
hier da ist noch so die kriegen mit der
Zeit diese diese diese Fugen drin und
dann kriegen die solche ja ich sag mal
dann setzen sich schnell Infektionen
rein und dann kommt es zu genannte
Panzer Nekrosen das sind also solche
Areale oder Panzer so Einschmelzung hat
und Kuchen und und
und wir müssen das schön sauber halten
vor allen Dingen auch
ja dass das wieder so Nachhalt das
dauert wir werden das gleich noch mal
auch mal locker desinfizieren aber
insgesamt sieht das so ganz gut aus so
wir müssen ein bisschen sputen das mögen
hier nämlich gar nicht gerne
das war da schön für die das nicht
ein bisschen Jod drauf machen nee
insgesamt gefällt mir das gut dann würde
ich sagen darf der Herr beim Umdrehen
ist Vorsicht geboten ja und das ist auch
nicht knallt ne
ja okay und die eigenen Füße nicht
dazwischen und die eigene Füße nicht
nein wir haben zwar alles sicher okay
sehr gut so das war
die beiden Seychellen Schildkröten haben
schon mehr als 100 Jahre auf dem Buckel
ein bisschen beruhigend
auch der zweite Kandidat muss in die von
ihnen so ungeliebte stabile Seitenlage
gebracht werden
gut okay
dann
fest
ja so
ah ja und das ist das was ich meinte die
Hände dazwischen
ja die sieht sehr furchtbar aus
aber dass das trocken ist ist gar nicht
so schlecht hier sieht man das so gut
schruppen wir noch mal alles sauber okay
vielleicht müssen wir doch mal mit dem
Dremel bei und alles was zur Mama
wegbringen
machen dann kommen wir mal mit dem
Dremel noch mal hier oben auch das ist
alles das kann alles raus
ich würde sagen für heute ne
okay gut
jetzt stehst du zum Glück Stahlkappen
gut wie gesagt Kandidat ist 100 120 das
ist auch schon Alter so wir sind fertig
mit diesem Knochenjob geht ein
fordernder Tag zu Ende